Sup? How you doing?
>> How am How you doing, man? You a Muslim?
>> I am a Muslim. Yeah.
>> Awesome. Awesome. So, what you think?
Islam or Christianity? Which one is
true?
>> What I think between Islam and
Christianity?
>> Yeah.
>> I think that Christianity is plenty of
nonsense. And Islam bring, you know, the
the truth. Yeah.
>> So, Christianity is full of nonsense.
And you're saying Islam brings the
truth. not full of nonsense but there is
um plenty of things that doesn't really
make sense in the Bible like lineages of
Jesus and you know plenty of stories
that are abominations.
>> What is what is the lineage of Jesus?
>> Mu one he comes from Abraham and um
Sarah then
>> do you do you affirm that lineage?
>> No cuz the Quran says there's something
wrong in it.
>> Okay. So what is the lineage of Jesus
then?
>> He comes from El Iran the family of
Imran. So, who's his uh who's his uncle?
>> I don't know. Maybe you tell me.
>> You said the Quran tells us.
>> Yeah, but you know, talking about
someone's uncle when I'm talking about a
precise lineage doesn't make sense.
>> You said you said he comes from Iran,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> All right. And so, who are the children
of Iran?
>> Mary.
>> And who else?
>> Uh the whole lineage up to Jesus, son of
Mary.
>> According to Sir Imran, who is the
descendant? Who are the children of
Imran? I have the whole lineage in my
mind, but that's what the Quran says.
>> Okay. So, it includes Aaron, doesn't it?
>> Yeah. Because the tradition is, you
know, Aaron tradition is a Levi and from
the Levi.
>> Wait, hold on. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop.
Where do you get this idea that Aaron's
lineage or tradition comes from Levi?
>> Exodus 7:1.
>> Wait, hold on. Wait, hold on a second.
You're going to the Bible.
>> What? You just said that the Bible's
lineage doesn't make sense, but then
you're going to the Bible to attain the
lineage. You get how that's confusing?
>> Let me let me get to the point. That's
what that's not what I say. I said
there's Can I talk?
>> Yeah. Where do you get this idea that
Aaron is part of the lineage of Levi?
>> Exodus 7:1.
>> So this the biblical lineage is the the
Bible is where we can find the authentic
lineage of these characters. Like Mary
in the Quran is from the Levi while in
your Bible he she's from uh Judah.
>> You didn't answer my question. You just
appealed to the Bible to get Aaron's
lineage. So does the Bible give us the
accurate lineage of these characters or
not?
>> No, not Mary. No,
>> not but Aaron.
>> Aaron accurate lineage. He's a divine.
That's true.
>> How do you know that that's true?
>> Because you study a hadith and you read
the Quran. Where does your where does
your hadith say that Aaron is of the
tribe of Levi?
>> I don't have I don't have it here. But
you don't have one to you.
>> You don't have one.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Let me bring the lineage of
Jesus in the Bible.
>> No. No. No. No. Bring me the lineage of
Aaron right now because you're saying
the you're saying you're saying the
Bible does not portray the lineage of
Jesus correctly, but then you pee to the
Bible to get Aaron's correct lineage.
>> You see how you're flip-flopping? I'm
talking about Jesus and Mary and you're
talking about
>> that link because cuz according to your
Quran that lineage links back to Aaron
correct?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Thank you. So that's why that's
why this matters. So what is So when
you're saying Aaron's lineage, you're
appealing to the Bible while rejecting
the Bible when it comes to Mary and and
Jesus's lineage.
>> Yeah. You see? Yeah. Because you keep
doing the same thing. So, let's probably
let's let's probably do something
different. How about we how about we
stay consistent and say, you know what?
Either the Bible is false and I can't
depend on it for anybody's lineage or
it's true and I have to be consistent as
my authority when it comes to the
lineage of these characters. Sound good?
>> This is consistent according to the
Bible. That's what you see.
>> Hey, Benson, don't ever request up on my
page again. You got it.
>> Are you running?
>> Don't Don't ever request up again. is
they willingly don't listen and then
they saw you running.
>> You look dumb and sound dumb, man. Had a
beanie on in the summer.
>> The boy Ahmed.
>> By the way, if we go with the Quran's
lineage of Jesus, Jesus is a nephew of
Aaron and Moses. And Mary is the sister
of Aaron and Moses. If we go with the
Quran's lineage,
>> and nowhere in the Quran does it mention
Levi, nor in your hadith doesn't mention
any of this. You got to steal from the
Bible while while at the same time
arguing against the Bible. Similarly,
how atheists steal from God to argue
against God.
>> Mhm.
>> Y'all are the same. Same spirit,
different skin. Man, you're on stage.
>> Yeah. What's up?
>> What's your religion?
>> I'm a Muslim. Alhamdulillah.
>> All right. So, what do you think?
Trinity is true. Jesus was crucified.
Islam is false. What do you want to
tackle?
>> Well, I would like to say let's put uh
the scriptures aside.
>> Can't do that for a moment. Okay, then
keep the scriptures as well. But
>> the trinity itself, just by logic, it's
unintelligible.
>> All right. Well, just to let you know,
we have a fun thing going on. Nick, for
quite a while, has been offering what is
it? 200.
>> Yep. 200.
>> $200 to prove that the Trinity is
illogical. And looks like you just
stepped in that field. So, go ahead,
tell us why it's illogical.
>> Okay. I would like to take the 200
because I'm a student. It will help me a
lot. M
>> I would appreciate it. Yeah. Thank you.
So you are saying as an ontological
sense in essence God is one right?
>> Is it an ontological sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Like when you are talking about what God
is there's one God.
>> Yeah.
>> And in persons there are three. The
father, the son and the hol holy spirit.
>> Yep. There one god. So when you are
describing these names as in essence and
persons, you need to describe what they
are as well. So if I were to say a
family one as in family, right? But in
persons, let's say there's father,
there's mother, there's a son, I can
tell there are three persons in a family
as well.
>> Okay. You have one family with multiple
persons. Yeah. What about it?
>> Yes. But uh what you are doing with
trinity is you are also saying the
father is a family. The son is a family.
The mother is a family. As
>> what are you describing? What are you
describing family to be
>> as God? The essence is one.
>> That's just going to be that's just
going to be that's not what family
means.
>> No, I'm I'm making a similarity as in
like an example. You are saying the son
is God, the father is God, the holy
spirit is God. Right. And they are like
they are not the same thing.
>> Mhm. So
>> they're not the same person.
>> Yeah. They are not the same person. So
as in son is different than father,
father is different than holy spirit.
>> Yep.
>> And they are god.
>> Yes.
>> If you would apply the same logic in a
family, family is one.
>> I I don't think that's going to be
analogous because the family doesn't
have one ontology.
>> No, it's one family.
>> Okay. But does that family have one
ontology?
>> Okay. Uh then
>> I guess I I was I would like I would
have to say yes because there's one uh
thing describes describing the whole
thing.
>> That's just wrong. Then they don't have
a family doesn't have one ontology.
That's just wrong.
>> The the point I'm trying to make is you
are saying all of these persons are God
but you cannot say God is three but they
are not one and same. So if you would
apply the same logic in like son is
different than father, father is
different than holy spirit and they are
all god at the same time you you would
also be able to say uh at least in a
sentence god is three without uh without
making a mistake to your religion.
>> Yeah. Yeah. God is three. God is three
persons. What's the issue? Well then
that that that cannot be the same like
God cannot be one and three at the same
time because
>> he can because he's one essence three in
personhood it's in two different
>> I think I think you believe God cannot
contradict himself right as in he cannot
make one and three being the same thing
is a contradiction because you are
playing with mathematics
>> oh okay so you can't be one in one sense
and multi in another sense
>> you can be in another sense but
>> okay in another sense Three persons, one
essence.
>> Three persons. Yes. But I'm not talking
about three persons. These three persons
are also God.
>> Yeah. We're saying there's one God, one
essence. Who are three persons?
>> But they're not the same, right?
>> They're not the same person. They have
the same essence.
>> Okay. As I said, they have different
wills, different consciences because
where are you getting that from? No.
>> What does personhood mean?
>> An underlying reality. An underlying
reality of a rational nature.
>> What?
>> It's an underlying reality of rational
nature.
>> Rational nature. So consciousness.
>> No.
>> What does that mean? You are rational n
rational essence. Nature.
>> Yes. Rational means you have a r It
means you have some sort of nature.
>> Yeah. Conscious.
>> And that nature and that nature provides
you with a mind.
>> Yeah. Will mind conscious.
>> You have to do you have to be conscious
to be a person.
>> Yeah.
>> What? Okay. Okay. So if you so if you
get knocked out and you're unconscious,
you're no longer a person
>> if you are dead.
>> No, you get knocked out exist.
>> No, you get knocked out in a fight. Are
you no longer a person?
>> Yeah, that's a loaded question because
you are talking about a person being
able to be conscious again in the
future.
>> Yeah. Your your issue is you saidary,
bro. You said it's a necessary condition
to have consciousness to be
>> because the consciousness still exists
like your brain is still working as in
when you sleep. It's not though. You're
knocked out. It's literally not.
>> Yeah. The brain is still working when
you're knocked out.
>> It's not. You're unc. So you're So when
you're So when you're knocked out, you
can you can do basic mathematics still.
>> You you as I said working brain is the
same not the same as being able to do
mathematics, but you are able to
breathe. Your brain is controlling your
muscles.
>> What does it mean to be Wait, what does
it mean to be a working brain?
>> Working brain is meaning like you have
consciousness and you are alive. So
that's why I said if you were to cease
to exist as in dead then you would no
longer be a person. Yeah.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> If you were to say knocked out knocked
out that's a loaded question because you
are uh putting him in a position where
in the future he will be able to think
again in uh aware of himself. But
>> what if what if we don't know what if we
don't know what if we don't know if
he'll have that in the future. We don't
know his future. He might he might not
wake up from
>> then you don't know that's that's that's
>> you might not be a person anymore.
>> Yeah. Let's say someone's in a coma.
>> If you cease to exist if you cease to
exist you are not a person, right?
>> Let's say you're in a coma.
>> Would you would you at least agree with
that?
>> No. Why not? Let's say I'll explain.
Let's say you're in a coma and you might
you might not ever have consciousness
again. You're in a coma.
>> But you you are asking a different
question. I'm like this conversation is
going I'm answering all the questions.
You need to answer the question.
>> You need to answer at least one of mine.
You need answers the entire time.
>> No, just answer it. One one thing. If
you cease to exist.
>> If you cease to exist.
>> Well, we don't believe that. That's not
what death is, bro. See, death isn't
ceasing to exist.
>> I'm not talking about death. If you
cease to exist,
>> if you just if God just snaps you out of
creation,
>> you you you think God is all powerful
and can create thing out of nothingness
and also
>> therefore make things cease to exist,
right?
>> Yes. So if God snaps us out of creation
like Thanos, then
>> so if God decided to make some someone
cease to exist, that's that's a possible
scenario in your paradigm. So don't play
with me like this is something
impossible.
What does that have to do with what does
it have to do with what I said at all?
>> My question is if someone cease to
exist, if he still is a person.
>> No. What does that What does that have
to do with what I said though?
>> So personhood
requires a consciousness. That's where
I'm getting.
>> What does that have to do with what I
said about being knocked out?
>> Knocked out means you still exist. Like
your mind is still there. When you die,
do you still
>> are you still are you still conscious
when you're knocked out?
>> Consciousness in a sense like uh your
brain is working and are you still
conscious when you when you get knocked
out?
>> So, as I said, that's a loaded question
because your brain is working. It it is
your brain is working.
>> I'm going to keep it I'mma keep it
simple, man, cuz you're I I got other
guests.
>> Would you your brain is still working?
If you are not unconscious, are you
conscious?
>> You are not aware of yourself. Let's
let's
>> So, are you conscious? Yes or no?
>> He's gone,
>> bro. Like, it's literally It's so hard
for them to answer basic questions.
>> It's It's By the way, guys, the answer
is no. Obviously, you're not conscious
when you're freaking knocked out. Like,
what? Don't make no dang sense.
>> Mustafa, you're up. How you doing?
>> Um, I'm very good. How are you, sir?
>> Good. Which one you want to tackle?
Trinity is true. Jesus was crucified.
Islam is false. Yeah, I think the
Trinity is fine. Uh, if you don't mind.
Uh, I know I'm not going to last longer
here because I mean, obviously you don't
like me.
>> Well, I I I No, it's not that I don't
like you. I just don't like when people
play games. If they're not direct,
>> I'm not playing games.
>> If you're not honest, let me finish,
please. If you're not honest, if they're
not honest, if they're not direct,
>> I'm honest.
>> Then, it's a waste of my time. That's
all.
>> Uh, I'm not going to waste your time.
>> All right. Uh so I have a very uh you
know simple question. If the trinity is
true, why all the Hebrew prophets in the
Tanakh in the Old Testament, they
believed in one God is mentioned
frequently.
>> We believe in one God too, bro.
>> Can you define Can you define what the
trinity is?
>> Yeah. Like son, father, and holy spirit.
Three distinct persons, right?
>> Three distinct persons in what?
>> Mean one essence of the godhead, right?
>> So one God, right?
Yeah. But uh I mean do Jews believe in
the Holy Spirit and the Son?
>> Yeah. Do you consider
>> Do you want to see the prophets? Is that
what you want? You want to see that the
prophets taught that God is
multi-personal?
>> We are going to have disagreement and
different explanation because
>> we will because remember we said we're
going to be honest, right?
>> Yeah, we're going to be honest. Of
course.
If if the
>> if the text demonstrates something,
>> I don't have the Mustafa cutting me off
again. This is why why you're not going
to last long. He notice he's saying,
"Let him speak while I'm speaking."
>> Yeah. Let me oversp speak you.
>> It's incredible, Mustafa. I don't have
to explain anything. You're not going to
have to explain anything. Nick isn't
going to have to explain anything. If
the text plainly demonstrates that God
is multi-personal, if that's what the
text says, then that's it. That's all.
Right.
>> All right. But we have to get the text
in its original text because the English
is let's be honest.
>> I agree. We can see we can use the
Hebrew, right?
>> Correct.
>> All right. So, let's go ahead and look
at how God is multi-personal in the
Hebrew scriptures. All right.
>> You want me pull up a verse you want?
You got one you want to look at?
>> Go ahead. Go ahead, Nick. All right.
>> All right. Um, let's see. We can just do
start with Isaiah 48. We just make it
easier. All right. Let's go to Isaiah
48. Start at verse 12.
All right. All right. Isaiah 48. I'll
start reading. Listen to me, O Jacob and
Israel. My called, I am he. I am the
first. I am also the last. Indeed, my
hand has laid the foundation of the
earth and my right hand has stretched
out the heavens. When I call to them,
they stand up together. So, who's
speaking there? Mustafa.
>> Um, the Lord
>> God, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, let's keep reading. Go down to
verse 15. I even I have spoken. Yes, I
have called him. I brought him and his
way will prosper. Come near to me and
hear this. I have not spoken in secret
from the beginning. From the time that
it was, I was there. Still God speaking,
right? Exactly.
>> Okay, I'll reread that. Come near to me
and hear this. I have not spoken in
secret from the beginning. From the time
that I was, I was there. And we've
already establishes God speaking. And he
says next, "And now the Lord God and his
spirit have sent me." So why does God
say that God and his spirit sent him?
>> Right. Can you tell me what the word God
is here?
>> Yes.
>> In in the original,
>> it's Yahweh. Yeah. We can li the Hebrew.
It's going to say, "And now the other
one, the other God,
>> it's also Yahweh." Also, it's it's also
Yahweh because it's referring to the
fact that Yahweh is multi-personal.
>> Incorrect. Can you open the Hebrew text
and just
>> Yeah. You don't believe it says Yahweh
in both parts?
>> No.
>> Okay, great. Fantastic. Get go to the
Hebrew. It's Isaiah 48.
>> All right.
>> Go to Isaiah 48 and uh you can go to You
can go to verse 16 to see that it does
in fact say Yahweh there.
>> Scroll down a little bit. See how it
says Yahweh there? Yeah. This is one
second.
>> It's only one Yahweh.
>> Yeah. So Yahweh was the one the most
high God was the one speaking when it
says my hand has laid the foundation of
the earth.
>> So where's the second you say two
Yahweh?
>> Yeah. The the first Yahweh is when we
read and it says my hand has laid the
foundation of the earth. Did Yahweh's
hand brother? You said two Yahweh,
right?
>> Yes. Because we already established that
verse 12.
You're not being honest. You're not
being honest.
>> Is Yahweh speaking in verse 12 and 13?
>> Brother. Brother. You're not being
honest. You have exposed yourself in
front of the viewers. You're not being
honest.
>> Yeah, there's no way he's a Muslim.
>> Is Yahweh speaking to honest? We agreed.
We agreed. You know the honesty. You're
not keeping honest.
>> Is Yahweh speaking?
>> Wait, wait, wait.
>> We agreed. You said there are two
Yahweh.
>> What did he stop though? What's he being
What's he being dishonest about?
>> Yeah, he said Yahweh spoke to Yahweh.
So, there are two words of Yahweh in the
text. Verse 14 has Yahweh too, dude.
Verse 14 has Yahweh dude.
>> No, no, we are speaking in the same
verse. You said Yahweh spoke to other
Yahweh. That's what we agreed upon and
then you opened it.
>> Yes. Because we already found that
Yahweh was speaking, brother. Oh my god.
Please, no games. No games.
>> Okay. So, let me ask a question. Who was
speaking? Was Yahweh speaking in verse
12 and 13? Yes or no?
>> No.
>> So, who is who is the one that laid the
foundation of the earth? If it's not
Yahweh, the first and last.
>> Yeah. The spirit of God. The angel of
God. Is that Yahweh or not?
>> No.
>> So Yahweh so Yahweh didn't create all
things in the Bible.
>> It doesn't say created everything in the
Bible.
>> Yahweh isn't the one that laid the
foundation of the earth.
>> Just just really quick. It says here,
"Listen to me, oh Jacob and Israel, my
called. I am he the first. I am also the
last." Who is that?
>> Yahweh.
>> So what is Yahweh?
>> Verse 12, Yahweh is speaking. Right? And
so it continues. He continues to say,
"Indeed, my hand has laid the foundation
of the earth, and my right hand has
stretched out the heavens. I when I call
to them, they stand up together." Right?
>> Yahweh speaking.
>> So Yahweh speaking, right?
>> One gut. One gut. No problem.
>> Good. Assemble yourselves all of you.
And here, who among them has declared
these things? Yahweh loves him. He shall
do his pleasure on Babylon and his arm
against the child shall be against the
Chaldans.
>> Good.
>> I even I have spoken. Yes, I have called
him. I have brought him and he will pro
uh and will prosper his way. All right.
>> All right.
>> Come near to me. Hear this. I have not
from the beginning. I have not spoken in
secret. From the time that it was I was
there. Yahweh speaking.
>> Yahweh speaking and
>> wait. Yeah. No problem. little progress.
>> Okay. So, Yahweh continuing and then
Yahweh continues and says, "And now the
Lord Yahweh has sent me and his spirit."
>> So, why does Yahweh say that Yahweh sent
him in his spirit?
>> Yeah, it's a very good question.
>> That's the truth right there.
>> Yeah. But, okay. So, first of all, uh
you said two Yahweh's right as a word,
right? No.
>> No. No.
>> No. as in the fact that Yahweh is
speaking and Yahweh is sent by Yahweh.
>> Brother, let's be honest. We agreed not
in, you know, the absence of
>> Yes. So, Mustafa, please deal with this.
You have Yahweh saying that Yahweh sent
him and his spirit. How many is that?
>> Uh, three.
>> Very good. So, in the Old Testament, we
see three persons who are identified as
God. Identify. You have Yahweh, you have
Yahweh who sends Yahweh, and then you
have the spirit of Yahweh. That's three.
That's exactly what the trinity is. The
father, the son, the holy spirit, the
son sent by the father and the spirit
comes with him.
>> Yeah. This is a very non-Christian
manipulation because
>> uh this is not the son or the holy
spirit. It says the spirit of god,
right? It doesn't say holy spirit. It
doesn't say I sent him. It doesn't say
the son. Just say yeah. Forget the
spirit. Forget the spirit. Why does why
does Yahweh say he sent by Yahweh?
>> First of all, this the first speaker
didn't say I'm Yahweh. I'm sending
Yahweh. We already established it's
Yahweh.
>> Yeah, we did. But it didn't say Yahweh.
Can we just agree on this?
>> What?
>> Goodbye.
>> This is what I'm talking about.
>> No, this is embarrassing.
Go
with with everything. I I want I want
you I don't want you to leave with
confusion. I want you to understand why
you're you're you're being kicked off.
Because you have already acknowledged
that Yahweh is speaking and that Yah
Please hear this. Please hear this. He
kicked us off.
>> You've already acknowledged that Yahweh
is speaking. You've already acknowledged
that Yahweh sent Yahweh with his spirit.
And then you have already acknowledged
that there's three that are identified
there. You already acknowledge that. So
then you going back to your original
question and argument of well uh well
does it say Yahweh like Yahweh Yahweh or
going back to that is showing that
you're being dishonest and you can't
progress.
>> This is why you're not one.
>> This is why you cannot last on my stage.
>> Respectfully respectfully take care of
yourself.
>> Embarrassing. Absolutely. It's cognitive
dissonance, bro. It's insane.
>> So stop stop requesting up on my panel.
Stop. You're no, you're no longer
welcome back. When you show you're this
dishonest and then you begin to play
stupid. That's it. Coloss.
>> Yeah,
>> Coloss. That's it. But thanks for the
clip, though. I appreciate it. All
right.
>> Y. Amen.
>> He asked for it. He got it and didn't
know what to do with it once he got it.
>> Didn't know what to Oh, this is a this
is a clearly a Christian manipulation.
It's in the Hebrew,
>> man.
>> This is This is 700 years before any
Christian is thought of.
>> We just reading, man. That's all. We
just read.